il était une fois une famille pauvre qui
a vu sa vie changer radicalement après
avoir gagné 100 millions d'euros à la
loterie
cette famille c'est la mienne l'étude là
première fois donald j sera pas là sur
mon anniversaire partout son ami
nous sommes monaco on arrivait un peu
moins de huit heures vous hall los
angeles
une de plus j'aime conduire
un camping car de cet humanime et mac
marines est bien plus qu'un dans l'est
on vient voir à quoi quoi qu'est ce que
vous faites là ready to 10 ans c'était
pas en train de tripoter normal j'ai
rencontré une fille super jeune femme
est très riche que fait tempère
l'enfance paris échanges me taire a mis
six touches docteur tu vois là j'achète
une clinique
bon c'est bien vous avez plus gros
produit tabouda mais grâce à chef du ch
tu peux devenir canons à eau savoir
qu'un décor hideux mais tu fais ayoub a
plein de fric à
rue du stade à profit la roche
les amish de mes amis sont mes amis ch 3
février au cinéma lui